we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
voicemail over the weekend with a very
interesting question that relates to
health care take a listen hi David I was
wondering this Medicare for all doesn't
get passed for whatever reason it just
can't be done do you think a 100% tax
write-off for medical instances would
pass so at least we could keep people
from going bankrupt over and medical
instances let me know what you think
about this thanks yeah this is an
interesting question so the idea is if
we can't get Medicare for all or sum
total up ending of the status quo system
that we have what about making all
medical expenses tax deductible that's
that's the question I like the idea and
what you're basically doing when you say
that medical expenses are tax deductible
if the average tax bracket or effective
tax rate in the US is I don't know what
it must be 20 to 24 percent whatever it
is you're basically saying the
government is going to give you a twenty
two or twenty four percent discount off
of your health expenses now already
there is expenses are deductible medical
expenses are deductible above a certain
level that level was lowered by the
donald trump tax plan that was like the
one i think there was one thing maybe
there were two small things that the tax
plan did that i agreed with that was one
of them which is lowering the threshold
at which taxes medical expenses become
tax-deductible i like this idea and the
the truth is that if you were able to do
that it would already be sort of
shifting some of the burden of people's
medical expenses to the government
because basically the the higher your
medical expenses the less tax revenue
the government gets so it would be a
really interesting idea to go in the
direction of saying let's make the
government a little more involved in
what we're doing here of course it's
allowing it's basically pushing the
government to subsidize private
for-profit insurers that's the downside
right if insurers realize that
everybody's getting a de facto twenty
two
twenty-five percent whatever depending
on their tax rate discount does that
open the door for them to raise prices
even more and that's something I would
be concerned about but it is a very
interesting idea and it's something that
I would I would likely support although
we would want to think about what
negative repercussions would there be we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today I'll explain to you why Pat wasn't
here today I'll talk to you about studio
updates over the weekend and much much
more get the bonus show please sign up
please sign up at wwlp.com or by
becoming a patron for as little as five
bucks a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show